bueno se esperaba una recuperación tras
la pandemia de Kobe 19 pero parece que
no se vaya a producir No aquí lo
atribuye usted
bien como bien decías y Venía escuchando
el programa Todo lo que viene sucediendo
en el último en los últimos años no solo
a partir de la pandemia sino en los
posterior o la pandemia la guerra la
Guerra de Ucrania por ejemplo que trató
la crisis energética a partir de las
sanciones y del conflicto no una serie
de conflictos internacionales de
conflictos mundiales que se vienen dando
en paralelos no solo en Ucrania sino la
atención también por ejemplo entre
Turquía y Grecia en el Egeo la atención
entre Estados Unidos y China por Taiwán
es decir que estamos en un contexto
internacional hoy de permanente tensión
de permanente tira y afloje entre las
potencias entre los países y Esto hace
que la economía no no termine de
recuperarse venimos golpeados por la
pandemia y ahora el golpe ha sido aún
mayor a partir de la Guerra de Ucrania
no Esto sumado va como decía la
presidenta de la omc sumado la crisis
climática a la falta de energía es un
combo y un cóctel complejo y muy
complicado de desarmar y cuáles cree que
son los principales signos de alerta en
la economía para considerar que
estaríamos cerca de una recesión bueno
son muchos pero uno de los principales
es la contracción por ejemplo en los
productos brutos internos posterior la
pandemia hubo un rebote y hubo un
crecimiento pero esto no se ha sostenido
al año siguiente Durante este año
Estados Unidos en los últimos tres
trimestres viene podría decirse ya
técnicamente que está en recesión por
ejemplo la inflación creciente en el
resto en todo el mundo no solo en
Estados Unidos en América Latina sino
también en Europa inflación Ya que en
algunos países llega a los dos dígitos
por lo cual estamos hablando de la
inflación más alta de los últimos por lo
menos 50 años Así que no tiene vistos de
aminorar en el corto mediano plazo sino
más bien todo lo contrario
despilarizarse tenemos una caída sin
precedentes en los últimos 40 años de la
libra esterlina en Gran Bretaña del euro
en Europa una caída muy grande también
rumores de corrida bancaria en Gran
Bretaña la última fue en 2007 y fue la
única que tuvieron en 150 años es decir
que económicamente en general hay un
panorama extremadamente complicado hay
muchos signos que hacen ver que estamos
yendo hacia una hacia una recesión
además de todo lo que tiene que ver por
supuesto con la escasez de energía y el
descontento social que esto va a generar
toda esta cuestión económica que está
sucediendo no pondría el foco y la lupa
en ver cómo responden las sociedades
frente a esto por ejemplo frente a la
racionalización de energía en Europa por
ejemplo